a marketing check I'm with involved in
analytics what am I talk about today is
is the experiences and developing our
software suite of products and the
lessons learned sort of historically
along the way
closing it on 20 years ago now I started
the autonomous analysis initiative when
I was at Dow Chemical basic notion was
that large corporations which I've
painfully discovered a great at
collecting data they're great at doing
records retention
it's that conversion of data to
something useful in that interim that
that's difficult so the focus here and
it's a result we really needed to
improve that at the efficiency as well
as the efficacy of developing insights
from data focuses predictive analytics
I left Dow Chemical in 2005 to start
evolved analytics and that resulted in a
mathematic package data modeler we've
got a wide variety of application
domains of clients around the world so I
sorta have to explain what what we do
the basic notion is that we're going to
use evolution to develop models from
data and what makes a good model is
simplicity and accuracy right and one
good simple model we're gonna reward
those and we're going to develop
algebraic equations so you know human
interpretive expressions but furthermore
in this process we're gonna look at the
we're gonna help lots and lots of models
but we really want the ones at this
location where it's the knee of the
pareto front the the best trade-off
between complexity and accuracy and
we're still going to get hundreds or
thousands of models there and and
they're all good they're all simple
they're all accurate
a lot of benefits to this you can view
this as a essentially an automated
hypothesis generator and refiner so
the implications that you have so now
I've got all these models which are
which are all reasonably good from a
deployment standpoint I can I can look
at them and I can say what variables are
in here we're most popular what variable
combinations we can really get a lot of
mining out of this this model set and
maybe focus our analysis in on a handful
of variables that are most usable from
an operational standpoint and we're
gonna get take that and but step cyka
you know all these models let's use
those models let's select diverse set of
these and and build ensembles and these
ensembles are really neat because they
will agree where they've been trained
where that presented data because
otherwise they wouldn't be good models
but we're will choose them so that
they're diverse and so if they're asked
to go into a new region of parameter
space then those then they'll diverge or
if the underlying system is undergone
some sort of change tilde diverge so you
know so we've got this trustable model
con except here's a response plot
Explorer the green dots a known data
point and what you see is if I bury that
dot that data point a variable away
while keeping the others constant my
uncertainty blows out because I don't
have data in that space so now I've got
this sort of trustable model the next
thing I can do is go off and and use
that guidance of the trust to guide
experiments because I can look for a
spot in parameter space which is most
uncertain and if I can if I can do this
that is the most valuable next
experiment for me to write okay so you
have in two slides what in a training
course I would cover for two days
there's a lot there's a lot of nuances
here behind the scenes
and somebody what happened and I got
okay people edited my slides okay so in
the beginning bounced around in the
beginning was the package I mean there's
things a thing of beauty 460 functions
extensive if you might even say anal
levels of documentation total control if
you're control freak you could build
your own custom workflows you know and
the reality is nobody cared right so so
what what you know what are the issues
of that and it's basically the users
were coming from outside the mathematic
community so they had to learn
mathematic in order to use the package
hitting shift enter is a remarkable
barrier to people I mean I don't know
why but it is and so as a result of it
go gout then but you know half my effort
was training the people in how to use
Mathematica and so that they could use
the package and and the users really
didn't care about Mathematica as
foundation they really wanted the power
of the analysis the other prominent in
retrospect is that a Mathematica
notebook wonderful though it is for
leave with an audit trail is linear and
this you know the analysis and insight
process is nonlinear so you know what do
we what do we do next and a fight so
then there was the GUI so we worked with
Ariel Sepulveda here in the room and and
develop this beautiful interface ease of
use all over being using you know
layering complexity with tooltips so
that you know your basic
your first view was going to be
something reasonably good but you can
get extra extra insight you know we
hammer the limits of what's possible and
dynamic this is a massive a massive
environment and and really is it was it
was good because the clients you know
we're really responding I mean I'm
getting almost no one at this stage of
the game
after this was developed he had a prior
mathematics mathematical background see
all right okay so so now we have the
packagin and GUI issues basically the
issue is we're still tied we're tied to
Mathematica it's built on top of
Mathematica so you need a you need a
mathematical license Wolfram's required
to be engaged to demo the software
because the the [ __ ] where that comes
out is the standard issue Baphomet the
demo can't write files can't can't do
anything that allows some sort of usage
we also had the need for concurrent
licenses becoming apparent
yeah you you basically you know
corporate environment and I wanted court
I want a concurrent license to be able
to deploy people because you know if I'm
selling into a General Motors or a
georgia-pacific or somebody like this
you know I want them to be able to
distribute widely and and get a whole
bunch of people a little bit pregnant so
I had I guess year ago year and a half
good for interns that I assigned to this
project and and they came through and
basically was two games in town flex era
and reprise boats are sort of miserable
the interns did learn the value of both
documentation and customer support in
this exercise
okay okay so now I have to go back
Ashley this slide was was an order it
was fairly early so philosophy from the
development standpoint is to me AI means
augmented intelligence see human has to
be in the loop and a model that I'm
going to deploy in anger I mean that
trust in that is established by both the
use of the ensemble's these trustful
models and the context the human context
in terms of selection of variables
selection of you know meta variables
that can be used in the development and
the other the other sort of yin and yang
of the deal is that automation is good I
mean because I you know I do not want to
fight like you have to do in mathematica
with machine learning to make sure the
data is purely numeric and and all the
stuff I mean the machine should be able
to handle this kind of stuff missing
data should you know if I've got
categorical data and I'm doing you know
regression modeling you know I should be
able to automatically convert that and I
should also be able to identify outliers
and and that's her stuff so enter the
app what we did is we went and got
ourselves an enterprise mathematical
license and packaged the GUI with CDF
player pro essentially embedded within
the package structure so the
installation process at least on an
automatic is you grab the icon on the on
the disk image drag it over at the
Applications folder and and boom you're
done of course I still have to supply
you with the license key because I'd
like to sell more than one license of
this in the world you have to go through
the exercise of size of code signing
let's vote Apple and did you search for
the Linux and windows worlds you know
now you're now you're having to do move
rather than the package which is is
generic Mathematica and uniform now
got OS specific installers for the major
operating systems and it behaves mostly
like a conventional out and a really
exciting thing is that people seem to
care so let's just go off and and see if
I can get this thing to move to ok just
to show you the demo yeah
ok so so that the opening splash screen
shows up I say open project you know as
you can see it's it's sitting here on my
dock just like a an app should set I'll
select and I'm gonna go to my favorite
demo sets choose and let's go for all
mushroom edibility show machine lane
name so this is a machine name so it's
the the application is filed driven so
so you've got lots and lots of modeling
good
I'll have multiple machines that you V&C
into and you want to see which one
you're actually staring at at the moment
and they're all writing to a shared
drive so I I select a target variable so
I got this mushroom that's edible or
inedible this is a a data summary table
letting me look at and happens to be a
purely categorical function but in the
normal mode for for our client bases
numeric prediction but it I think it's
sort of fun to look at to look at this
and I can I can sit here and I can take
a snapshot and I can go to my reports
and I could say let's move it to the
report and now I've got it moved it into
the report so I can leave an audit trail
the downside of the CDF player is at
this point I'm not allowed to type in
the in the in the package version where
you've got full Mathematica I can edit
and rearrange this notebook and and do
annotations but at least I can save it
and and do good things along that line
analyze my models you know so you see
this is just sort of a standard-issue
app now I can I can come over here and I
can look and I say what a what's the
dimensionality of my models how many
variables do I have required in my
models and I've gotten this particular
four or five variables I'm layering the
information to say how many should be
included I can focus in on which
variable sets that's not the the focus
here I will want to show you the notion
of an ensemble yeah so maybe my model
summary table to look at you know basic
statistics and and things extracted out
of the model come on darling
and you know yeah you layer the
complexity I can come in here with
controls and sort of expand things it's
you know very responsive from you know
this is 100% you know Mathematica
nothing nothing extraneous out of the
deal if I look at my response plot
Explorer in this case I'm going to be
seeing you know I've got my data
embedded for odor which if you can good
enough you can you can see I don't have
any data with odor there we go with a
fishy smell to my to my mushroom with
those other things being held constant
so my uncertainty blows out and I don't
you know I probably don't want to find
cover a mushroom with all these
attributes in its and it's supposed to
be edible but now I don't you know I
don't know that I should go forward and
I can sort of freely vary things and if
it's categorical it will map to being a
button rather than a slider so just you
know really a neat sort of application
so and also you know smart enough to
know that if it's got categorical data
you know don't connect the dots between
the points they really should be they're
not covering that space so so we have
this happen people are actually caring
and and it's very exciting you know you
still have some barriers we still have
the the notion of most effective
technology corporations I mean you get
into organizations that if it can't be
done with SAS it's not worth doing right
so we still have to getting them to
think different getting them to certify
the app and put it up on their software
shelves and still
I mean it's normal sort of barriers for
corporate IT I'm excited to hear about
the the rumored processed progress on
xlsx import because that has been a real
pain in the kombucha for years having to
tell people that it'll convert it to a
CSV file and then you can import I mean
just not good this is a massive dynamic
module so there are dragons that are
that live in dynamic we've beaten on
both most of them there are imposed
limits on on file sizes you probably
don't want to go above a million records
in the GUI version whereas you're sort
of not really limited in the in the
package where you're operating a
notebook interface you know I think the
record for data modeler is 26,000
variables but you know a couple you know
a couple thousand inputs is probably
reasonable the model search just
basically looks and says how many cores
do you have on your machine will going
to launch independent searches with
random starting points random starting
models and just and grind away and
unfortunately kernels sometimes go rogue
they disappear doesn't really affect
anything but they still go rogue which
which is not what I like and then for
CDF you know leaving that audit trail
I'd really like to have the user be able
to type in not execute a notebook but at
least type into it an annotation so so
acknowledgments
first of all ariel built the the GUI
fantastic job i may have done a smidgen
of gooeys and dynamics and I'm gonna
happily pay Ariel for that and he his
partner ah really ah no did the app
conversion where we took the GUI and
embedded the CBF
there and and build all the installers
got it then do a shout out and and my my
wife asked me why of all your beautiful
birds that you photograph you had you
know a Roseate Spoonbill in which i
think is the most beautiful ugly bird in
the world and i said it was clearly
shouting outright so Andre and Wolfram
were essential in getting this together
and then for the interface design Teresa
and Katia made it not look like a
Mathematica GUI interface I mean the use
of the color of the use of the layout a
lot of the focusing so that wraps me up
are there any questions